si durante el día de hoy ucrania y rusia
celebrarán una nueva ronda de
negociaciones para alcanzar un acuerdo
de paz para poner fin al conflicto
bélico que se está llevando a cabo en
ucrania esta reunión ocurre al mismo
tiempo de otro encuentro clave que se
celebra durante el día de hoy un
encuentro en roma donde se reunirán
china y eeuu para analizar el conflicto
ucranianos recordemos que china es un
país considerado aliado de rusia y todo
esto además ocurre en un momento en el
que continúan los enfrentamientos en
ucrania se han vuelto a disparar aquí en
la ciudad de libia nuevamente las
sirenas durante la madrugada y en el día
de ayer se produjo un ataque que
preocupó a un ataque contra una base
militar que se encuentra a 50 kilómetros
de aquí y muy cerca de la frontera con
polonia un país que es miembro de la
unión europea y también de la
organización del tratado del atlántico
norte lo que ha hecho disparar la
preocupación en las cacerías
occidentales